[Música]
el gobierno de Colombia y la guerrilla
del ejército de liberación nacional se
sientan hoy en Caracas en la mesa de
diálogo para así reiniciar el proceso de
negociaciones de paz suspendido en el
año 2019 por el entonces presidente Iván
Duque quien tomó la decisión tras el
ataque contra una escuela de policía en
la ciudad de Bogotá que dejó 26 personas
fallecidas nos acompaña nuestro estudio
Luis Eduardo Bocelli se les analista de
temas de paz y conflicto armado asesor
de la fundación paz y Reconciliación en
Colombia Gracias Luis Eduardo por
acompañarnos esta mañana del lunes soy
muy buen día Raúl buen día y muchas
gracias por esta oportunidad de diálogo
Este es el séptimo intento para lograr
la paz con la guerrilla del ejército de
liberación nacional colombiano conocida
como lln hasta ahora todos estos ensayos
anteriores habían fracasado que hay de
diferente esta vez
bueno está si es la sexta ocasión y
realmente esto nos ha solucionado por
dos razones uno porque no ha habido
ningún gobierno que tenga una propuesta
de negociación viable con el Ln y porque
el Ln Siempre fue una segunda prioridad
entonces entre no tener una oferta de
negociación y no ser prioridad pues
tenemos lo que tenemos ahora
afortunadamente los astros están
alineados y para este gobierno el elen
es prioridad y para este gobierno si hay
oferta de negociación o sea En este
gobierno si hay una oferta para poder
llevar adelante la negociación cuál es
esa oferta del gobierno de Gustavo Petro
hacia la guerrilla lln
la oferta es una una idea de cambio y
democracia de más calidad sea el
gobierno del presidente Gustavo Petro y
la vicepresidenta Francia Márquez vienen
a hacer tareas históricas en la sociedad
colombiana que no se han hecho y que
tienen que ver con ampliar una precaria
democracia salir de tantas exclusiones
de tantas inequidades Y eso es lo que
hace viable esta negociación también
esto se marca en el proceso de paz Total
que lanzó el gobierno del presidente
colombiano Gustavo Petro realmente es
posible alcanzar la paz total en un país
y tan conflictivo o como Colombia
digamos y y tan difícil no que ha sido
alcanzar todas estas negociaciones de
paz con estos grupos Insurgentes
nosotros necesitamos construir una un
orden de democracia y lo hemos sido
construyendo en los últimos 30 años o
sea el hecho de que hoy el presidente
venga de un acuerdo de paz del primer
acuerdo de paz significa que la sociedad
colombiana ha recorrido un camino de
ampliar esta precaria democracia pero Le
falta mucho y yo creo que este gobierno
es consciente de que no solamente hay
que criticar los frutos amargos de la
violencia que son pues todas las
tristezas que vivimos todos los días las
masacres los muertos los asesinatos Esos
son los frutos amargos pero ese las
raíces de ese árbol son la exclusión y
la inequidades Entonces yo creo que este
gobierno sí quiere trabajar sobre esa
ese orden de exclusiones y inequidades
haciendo cambios entonces esa es la idea
de la paz total transformar las
condiciones que han dado origen a la
violencia es una tarea enorme y yo creo
que el mayor desafío de salir de la del
narcotráfico lo cual no lleva un tema
internacional muy complicado pero
Mientras tengamos narcotráfico va a ser
difícil una Colombia en paz como lo es
para México o lo es para Guatemala o
bueno para muchas regiones hablabas de
desafíos Luis Eduardo y le preguntó
cuáles son los principales puntos a
tratar y digamos los más difíciles para
llegar a un acuerdo final con lln no yo
creo que el gobierno y el Ln tienen todo
para ir hacia adelante lo que se quieres
que exista una dinámica de participación
en la sociedad que las dos partes
acuerden y que rápidamente se pueda ir a
los temas humanitarios y aún ese
bilateral o sea en un ambiente de paz y
con una dinámica de participación de la
sociedad que las dos partes tienen que
acordar Esto va a ir hacia adelante es
positivo que el gobierno de Gustavo
Petro haya también decidido incluir en
estas negociaciones con el nn a su ferro
opositor del gobierno como lo dejan José
Felix lafouría Por supuesto que sí o sea
porque la Paz es un propósito nacional
entonces que un señor como José Feli
laforique representa un sector político
y gremial que ha sido tan contradictor
de la paz tan tan tan caracterizado en
sus ideas entre este esfuerzo de
negociación va a ser una es un gran
aporte y una gran noticia qué le puede
aportar de diferente José Félix él él va
a aportar la mirada del centro
democrático del va a aportar la mirada
del mundo rural tan poderoso y con ese
mundo recuerdos por ejemplo ya este
gobierno ha hecho un acuerdo con fedegan
para comprar tres millones de detalles
lo cual muestra una un ánimo de de
concertación de diálogo de que es
posible llegar a acuerdos Igualmente en
ese tema del Ln la voz de José feria
laforid puede colocar los énfasis de
ellos y del mundo del centro democrático
y Buscar puentes hacia una paz viable
que que hay que construir con el Ln Luis
Eduardo estás a conversaciones se van a
llevar a cabo en la ciudad de Caracas la
capital venezolana y le pregunto cómo
favorece este restablecimiento de las
relaciones entre Bogotá y Caracas para
que estas negociaciones lleguen a un
buen final bueno Venezuela siempre ha
sido un protagonista del esfuerzo de paz
O sea la primera vez que el Ln se sentó
a una mesa fue en 1991 en Caracas y de
ahí para acá Venezuela siempre ha tenido
un involucramiento positivo en el
esfuerzo de paz
Venezuela también ha sufrido este
conflicto porque el conflicto colombiano
se fue también para Venezuela
cuatro décadas la presencia del elen en
Venezuela Data desde el principio de los
años 80 así como el estado colombiano ha
perdido su soberanía Igualmente el
estado venezolano ha perdido la
soberanía sobre su territorio entonces
Venezuela es un gran protagonista de
este esfuerzo de paz y afortunadamente
Venezuela ningún gobierno Ni antes de
Chávez ni después de Chávez ningún
gobierno en Venezuela ha apostado por
atizar el conflicto colombiano lo que
han apostado es por resolverlo por
ayudar a solucionarlo entonces la
presencia de Venezuela de su gobierno en
este marco de entendimiento de los dos
gobiernos Es una muy buena noticia Luis
Eduardo ya ya para finalizar nuestra
conversación digamos lo más difícil de
estos acuerdos de paz en comparación
también con lo que hemos visto con estos
acuerdos de paz de la ex guerrilla de La
FARC de su implementación vemos que
todavía esta implementación de los
acuerdos de paz con la ex guerrilla de
La FARC pues no se han incumplido a su
cabalidad hay muchísimos problemas
entonces se puede hacer y que tienen que
hacer el gobierno del presidente Gustavo
Petro para resolver todos los puntos
pendientes del acuerdo de paz logrado
con hacer ya de La FARC y además la
buena implementación de este nuevo
acuerdo si se llega con la guerrilla lld
Bueno este gobierno tiene el firme
compromiso de llevar hacia adelante el
acuerdo firmado con las que estamos
cumpliendo en estos días seis años del
2016 Entonces ese acuerdo ha sido
incumplido por el gobierno Duque pero
ese acuerdo va a ser cumplido por el
gobierno del presidente Petro y la
vicepresidenta Francia Márquez entonces
primer punto va a haber un compromiso en
el tema rural y en el tema de la
participación política y Buscar
alternativa frente al tema de
narcotráfico O sea no hay duda de que
este gobierno va a cumplir ese acuerdo y
lo segundo en el acuerdo con el Ln hay
una muy buena noticia Y es que las dos
partes están en sintonía de hacer
acuerdos parciales y llevarlos adelante
Entonces yo creo que en los próximos
meses muchos de los temas que se
discutan en una dinámica de sociedad
deben quedar involucrados en el plan de
desarrollo que se está formulando para
su implementación de manera inmediata
Entonces vamos a ver una negociación en
que van a ver acuerdos e implementación
de manera simultánea muy rápidamente que
tan lejos estamos de este acuerdo final
digamos cuánto se puede tardar esta mesa
de negociación teniendo una ruta Clara
como la estamos hablando acá Bueno aquí
hay aquí hay tres grandes puntos inicial
que son
democracia y transformaciones para la
paz esos puntos se pueden trabajar en un
horizonte de dos años Yo diría que todo
todo el cuerpo del acuerdo de lo que hay
que hacer se puede construir en dos años
y utilizar los otros dos años para los
puntos de verdad justicia y reparación y
reincorporación del Helen usar anime yo
creo que está en el corazón se puede
hacer en cuatro años la primera parte
gruesa de las de Los acuerdos para una
visión compartida de paz se pueden hacer
en un horizonte de aquí al 2024